today's topic takashi 69 why do you may
not know about the physics 9 is a rap
artist he made his name by trolling and
putting out a lot of music so he's part
of a street gang he ended up snitching
on them
y'all got you know basically they were
about to be sentenced to a long time in
prison takashi 69 who made his persona
on being a gangster I decided to snitch
on everybody and after about almost two
years in prison he's just been released
as if a couple weeks ago and yeah
everyone was expecting to stop trolling
stop all that stuff so this is the the
live that apparently the two million
people decided to tune in for and not
anybody every famous person I've ever
heard of in this face everybody
everybody wants to see what snitch nine
has to say if you see all this growth so
listen I just want to see
[Music]
you know that I be talking about you
know why people so mad cuz they thought
it was over for me they counted me out o
yo u yo u rat it's alright it's over for
you Jack could never doctor never
cooperate with the government and come
back Jack could never do that
I'm a living legend not the age of 24
years old you hear me
look at the look at these room 1.6
million shout out the Tories shout out
the Drake shot out the bat money John
[ __ ] can never stop playing stop
playin look at this one point six main
1.6 million now let me break it down I'm
sorry I want to say that I'm sorry to my
fans because you know what it wasn't
worth it it wasn't and I'm gonna tell
you what if there is a street cold right
if there is a street code and there's
something so so called is loyalty and
everything and no snitching and all of
that I get it right but where was the
Luigi when you were sleeping my baby
mother where was the Lord see when you
was caught on the white stop trying to
tell me what was the lawyer to when he
tried to kidnap my mother
where was the lawyer T when you still
means that lets me where was that so who
broke it first I I get it don't fight
fire fire I'm sorry but what did I do
wrong
be loyal to [ __ ] that's [ __ ] my baby
moms belonging to [ __ ] that kidnap me
beat the [ __ ] out of me on video and
everything
I think there's values and then there's
dope [ __ ] and it just so happens that
this man makes doper [ __ ] then like
people weigh his dope [ __ ] way higher
than they do their own value so it'd be
like yeah yeah snitching is wrong
brother damn this [ __ ]
you know it's kinda like people we black
man women's rights was rights but that
remix to ignition though you know it's
hard for some people I hate that I like
this I just want to stamp in the name
you know what very good point because if
they were Arkin we've been knowing that
this was going on yeah but when he goes
satisfied we were like all in with it
yeah we were all in with it until you
got prosecuted but still would you said
yeah people back yeah well if you expose
these values if you say you bought that
street life they live by that code the
reality is people don't live by codes
anymore doesn't mean I'm gonna reward
them doesn't mean I'm gonna say it's a
good thing I'm just telling you it's the
way of the world the whole business
which people have lost sight of a code
people don't live by that stuff Brett
it's like the wire the wire is my
favorite because it starts off and you
know initially and you see that there's
a code set and as the seasons progress
and new crews come in you realize that
these new [ __ ] they don't play by the
same rules and the wire kind of
foreshadowed that the way the streets
change of the way
the game has changed and all the old
heads who seemed in play invincible all
dying one by one cuz the new kids don't
care yeah whenever there's a renewal
young kids coming in they have to prove
themselves and they ha yeah they don't
care the code the code that's all yeah
so I think that's what Takashi reveals
about all of us at least as a society as
a whole maybe not about you individually
maybe you find it unacceptable and you
like your bump this duty corny out of
100 but the number for the society at
large the numbers it's over man their
numbers it's over man I'm supposed to be
Louie to that no you know what you what
it is
ya don't want to accept the fact that
doses or true facts yeah I don't want to
exit God understand why snitch I
understand yeah I don't want to
understand it's not that I don't
understand you I don't want to
understand that then this kid really was
a he moved
families out of poverty he he paid for
school for all of the members whatever
but he snitched on them why were they
law you to me cuz I when I met when I'm
that son he was sleeping on the road
I'll give him money look listen I'm a
rainbow Mexican here kid I rap turn
around I'm not about that gang [ __ ] but
listen I know how to get us out
you wasn't worried to me weather weather
which I understand y'all understand and
I know you understand you I don't want
to understand all right let me take
before I got locked up right before I
got locked up that rainbow hair [ __ ]
takashi snuff him that rainbow hair kids
him that rainbow hey kid
yeah didn't really have a reason to
dislike me just because I screamed and
raps and I got rainbow head that was
your reason right
oh he's mad loud that was your reason
but then now I got a reason so of course
the go-to is oh he snitched right he's
right so that shall go to which I
understand and I don't blame you I can't
blame him this isn't I'm sorry I'm sorry
to my fans because they don't deserve
that my my family my mother my family
don't deserve that and I'm sorry but
y'all not gonna break me down like five
there's something wrong listen I
snitched
I ratted who was I supposed to be loyal
to if you can't be loyal to me out here
and a free world and you my baby mom and
while I'm out until making money for all
of us you back at home sleep my baby mom
then I get kidnapped being try to kill
me if you can't be lawyer to me out here
in the free world
woman tieu think about what I held it
down you wouldn't violate me in the
prison one of the smartest move I know
you smart why do you say smoke is gonna
gain all of the people all true yeah
yeah they did doing bad and they do do
the stuff like that and he's not saying
I'm sorry I snitch because like it
doesn't represent Who I am as a person I
am better than that I didn't I didn't
think that the world what you saw in
court
mmm does not represent me he said no I
did that you appreciated how he came out
why we came
was a snitch I don't we said that but
I've said that an apology should be done
I'm sorry about this this this and that
I respect the fine even said hey I don't
even blame you for thinking I'm a snitch
you have the right to do that mm-hmm I
get that I feel like explain the
situation and not make it feel sorry for
himself and then after that there's a
whole trophy so that's the only part
that I feel it I wanted with you no I
think what this whole thing reveals
about us as a society is that this whole
you know gangster persona all this
snitching business they don't hold any
water like it used to that shit's done
with this guy ain't a is a snitch he's
admittedly a snitch and he's gonna have
a successful career and that's what's
really
now that he's no longer involved in that
gang you know he's not gonna be valdez
going on tour absolutely and there's
going to be some incident but he's gonna
have security you know why I knew he was
going back is it cuz he was offered a
record deal while he was in prison no no
I have nothing to do with that I have
nothing to do that's a pretty good
indication everybody's right but the
reason why I knew that he would be okay
is Drake still has a career Drake still
has a career and he's known to have
ghost riders if you had ghost riders 15
years ago it was done it was dead 15e
there was no turning back from that oh
you have go okay so you faked okay
people or not hmm
but now he has a career it's a known
fact when people started defending great
like oh well you know what
Drake is a brand so there's multiple
people where I was like I co-write the
game changed the game I feel like for
most people are the hierarchies like in
terms of what's the worst thing you can
do in the game I feel like snitching is
always gonna be way above having a
ghostwriter so I don't know if that's a
real yeah I understand that I'm not
saying that it's having a ghostwriter
and finishing on people is the same
thing what I'm saying though is that
when I saw that he got away with having
a ghostwriter and it was known that
people trying to blast him and he came
back and people didn't get me
yes Drake I neither one day and it was
all good I was like okay the whole
business is
hmm yeah cuz I was like I cuz it
possible this guy makes it and people
don't give y'all got bad at me when I
said yo snitch over this Corona stuff
but like you
he waited I'm learning from the best
he's gonna make it big he's about to hit
that Latin Marty's gonna hit that lot
and market so hard and just take it to
another level I don't think you guys
understand how much this guy's gonna win
and people gonna get mad because they're
watching the same transition they're
watching Avon Barksdale getting pushed
out by Marlo's crew that's what's
happening great reference so anyways
that's it for today's video we want just
to do a little quick cap on this but we
want to hear your thoughts what do you
guys think about the Koski six nine
coming out on the scene we want to hear
your thoughts right now
[Music]
wait what's wrong with mascara mascara
poof a massage now I see shout out to
all my Haitian people they trying to get
their opportunities up em yeah we must
defeat premier fashion about they will
run full of [ __ ] I used to wrong way
bring [ __ ] cuz you quicker pull trigger
I'm fat [ __ ] definition of a real
legal definition of them to [ __ ] the
definition of a [ __ ] that's a good bar
not a good bar
it's a sarcastic cake is the definition
a cake mmm you mean you sarcasm the
definition of